apple just unveiled its latest iphone se
and while the company focused on the
device's new attributes like 5g its
biggest attraction is probably what
isn't new the home button if you're
wondering why apple phased it out of
most phones but hasn't killed it off
completely i'll explain but first a
little history and why the home button
matters if you're an iphone user prior
to 2017 tapping the home button is
probably etched into your muscle memory
if your phone froze home button if you
needed to unlock it home button need to
access siri you get it apple swept us
all away in 2007 with its first iphone
and it looked incredibly modern
just a simple sleek glass screen with a
circular button in the original iphone
the home button served one main purpose
take you to your home screen the next
year the button helped us take
screenshots for the first time with the
iphone 3 came voice control which you
can think of as a primitive version of
siri then the iphone 4 let you fast tap
the home button to switch between apps
in 2013 the iphone 5s home button gave
us a touch id fingerprint sensor after
registering multiple fingers you could
use the home button to authenticate
itunes and app store purchases in 2016's
iphone 7 the button got a revamp losing
its clickiness and adding touch sensing
capabilities then on the next year's
iphone 10
poof
gone suddenly you had to program your
iphone to recognize your face and swipe
up from the bottom of the screen to go
home and people on social media were
clearly outraged when apple decided to
get rid of it just check out the tweets
and then the great reversal as some of
us were coming to grips with the
possible loss of the home button forever
2020's second generation iphone se
looking almost identical to the iphone 8
kept the home button around for those of
us who wanted it we love how simple and
useful the home button was you could
argue it was the first smartphone
feature you never had to learn to use
getting rid of the home button also made
unlocking your iphone more complicated
sometimes like when you were wearing a
mask if your phone didn't recognize your
face you had to enter your password and
that's really annoying at least it was
until apple sent an update to fix it but
home buttonless iphones do actually have
perks it's one less thing to break you
probably no longer trigger that siri
ding by accident and apple says face id
is more secure than relying on your
fingerprint touch id has shown up in new
spots apple put touch id in its max
starting with a 2016 macbook pro you
also get a sense of the old touch id
button and some of apple's latest ipads
which added the tech to a power button
up top so what does this mean for the
future of the home button will apple
keep it around here's what we do know
apple keeps pushing its vision forward
regardless of our possible resistance to
change remember apple killed the
headphone jack stopped including
chargers in the box with your new iphone
and stopped including wired headphones
in the box with every new iphone
purchase but apple also wants to attract
more customers and one way of doing that
is to deliver a budget iphone like the
sc with older parts that's cheaper to
produce than tech to read your face but
apple analyst jean munster says face id
will become cheaper over time and the
home button probably won't be around
forever the simple answer is that if you
love touch id and that home button you
better buy an iphone now because i think
that in the next one to two years that
will be a thing of the past but there's
no need to mourn just yet because it may
pop up in other forms the home button
could show up as an in-display
fingerprint reader like what you'd find
on some samsung galaxy smartphones you
can add your own home button to your
iphone using apple's assistive touch
feature you can find it in your
accessibility settings and it'll give
you an on-screen circle that acts like a
home button but for now if you prefer
any of apple's more cutting edge iphones
the virtual home button will have to do
do you want to keep up with the latest
tech and find out more about how things
work and where they come from please
subscribe and be sure to comment below
and let me know what i should
investigate next we'll be in touch
[Music]